INTRO:
The top two purposes of every for-profit company
is to offer as much value as possible and
bring home as much profit as possible.
Some companies are particularly good at providing
value while others are phenomenal at generating
profits, but very few companies are able to
strike a balance that pleases the peveryone.
One company that has managed to achieve this,
however, is Visa.
Generally, it's the retailer or seller paying
credit card and debit card fees, so most customers
never bat an eye.
To them, using a card is much more convenient
than carrying cash and change.
And as for sellers, most of them view the
1-3% processing fee as an acceptable investment
because accepting cards brings in so much
more traffic.
I mean just imagine where online sales would
be if it wasn’t for cards.
On the other side of the coin, Visa is pretty
happy as well.
Even though they only make a small fee on
each transaction, Americans alone spent $6.7
trillion through credit and debit cards in
2019, and 60% of that was through Visa.
Aside from pulling in massive revenue, Visa
has 0 COGS or cost of goods sold which means
that their gross profit margin is literally
100%.
Even after you account for operating expenses
and taxes, Visa is able to bring in 51% of
their revenue as net profit.
So, here’s the story of the most profitable
company in the world.
BANKAMERICARD:
Taking a look back, the origin of Visa dates
all the way back to 1956 to Bank of America.
At the time, credit cards were already quite
popular amongst middle class Americans, but
the system was by no means centralized or
streamlined.
Generally, merchants issued their own cards
that could be used to make purchases at their
stores and be paid off at the end of the month.
But the problem was that each card was specific
to the merchant, so people had to carry a
card for every retailer they shopped at.
And at the end of the month, they had to pay
off several bills.
Ironically, the situation is basically the
same today as people use different cards for
groceries, travel, and gas to maximize on
their points.
But theoretically, people can get away with
just 1 or 2 credit cards if they wanted to.
In the 1950s, however, this was not possible.
Many smaller banks had already tried to create
an all-around credit card, but given their
relatively small customer bases, these never
picked up steam.
When Joseph P. Williams, the product development
leader at Bank of America, suggested creating
a credit card, executives weren’t quite
convinced.
They feared that not enough Americans would
adopt the system and that merchants would
fight back, but after a bit of convincing,
Joseph was able to get approval for a soft
launch in Fresno, California.
The executives felt that Fresno was big enough
to give the system a shot, but it was also
small enough that if things went bad, the
company wouldn’t lose too much money.
Something else to note is that Bank of America
had 45% market share in Fresno, so they had
the cards stacked in their favor.
Anyway, on September 18, 1958, Bank of America
finally launched BankAmericard by shipping
65,000 cards to Fresno residents.
EARLY BACKLASH:
The launch in Fresno actually went pretty
well, and Bank of America was feeling comfortable
in expanding the program.
But then, rumors started to roll around that
another major bank was going to launch their
own credit card in San Francisco.
San Francisco was Bank of America’s home
market, so they couldn’t just let some competitor
beat them to market.
Bank of America doubled down on BankAmericard
and pumped up card issuance through the roof.
By March of 1959, they had sent out cards
in San Francisco and Sacramento.
By June, they added Los Angeles and by October,
they had issued over 2 million credit cards.
In terms of popularity, BankAmericard was
a massive success as 20,000 merchants were
accepting the card.
In terms of the media and profitability though,
BankAmericard was having a rough time.
You see, Joseph had vastly underestimated
the number of people who would take advantage
of the service.
Joseph anticipated that only 4% of accounts
would become delinquent, but the actual number
came in at 22%.
In the meantime, BankAmericards were the perfect
tool for fraudsters leading to the rise of
credit card fraud.
Now, Bank of America had thought about this,
and their terms of service specified that
customers would be liable for fraudulent charges.
But the media and politicians just ate this
up and destroyed the reputation of BankAmericard.
By 1960, Bank of America had racked up $20
million in losses, and Joseph would throw
in the towel by resigning.
Bank of America, however, was determined to
make this work.
They had seen how quickly merchants and customers
adopted the system, and they knew that they
had something massive on their hands.
Bank of America sent out an apology to their
3 million customers, and they simply stayed
the course.
By May of 1961, the venture would turn profitable,
but Bank of America didn’t make a fuss about
it.
They let the media continue to paint BankAmericard
as a tool for fraudsters as this simply deterred
competitors from entering the space.
This strategy worked for a couple of years,
but by 1966, it was clear that BankAmericard
was making bank.
INTERNATIONAL EXPANSION:
Initially, BankAmericard was only meant for
California because federal laws restricted
Bank of America from directly expanding to
other states.
But, an up and coming competitor called Master
Charge had figured out a work around.
Master Charge had created an alliance between
a bunch of regional banks to circumvent federal
laws.
Seeing this, Bank of America decided to do
the same thing, and given their brand power,
this strategy was extremely powerful.
Starting in 1966, Bank of America began signing
licensing agreements with banks outside of
the state, but they soon came across another
federal hurdle.
In 1970, the federal government would outlaw
banks from sending unsolicited credit cards
to Americans.
So, Bank of America could no longer just send
the cards to as many people as they could
and hope that people would bite.
But really, this was a bigger problem for
competitors than Bank of America.
Bank of America had already sent out over
100 million credit cards by the time this
law came around.
So, the law really just stifled competition.
In the meantime, Bank of America took this
opportunity to focus on international expansion.
Between 1968 and 1977 for example, Bank of
America partnered with an alliance of Canadian
banks to issue a credit card named Chargex.
Similarly, they would bring out Carte Bleue
in France and they also brought out options
in Japan, the UK, and Spain.
But as the card spread around the world, BankAmericard
started to become a larger and larger part
of Bank of America.
BankAmericard was no longer Bank of America’s
card, it was simply a popular card that was
owned by Bank of America.
In other words, BankAmericard was becoming
an independent business that was no longer
reliant on Bank of America.
And, Bank of America was actually stifling
the reach of BankAmericard.
BIRTH OF VISA:
Here’s the thing, not everyone in the world
is big fans of America especially during the
Cold War and the inflation crisis of the 1970s.
Many international customers refused to get
a card that was associated with Bank of America.
If the bank was named Chase or Wells Fargo,
they might’ve had an easier time with international
customers, but their name was literally Bank
of America.
Now, Bank of America isn’t actually a central
or national bank like the Bank of Canada or
the Swiss National Bank, but the name does
create such an image.
Aside from this association, BankAmericard’s
dealings became increasingly messy.
As Bank of America signed deals with various
banks around the world, they agreed to varying
transaction fees, varying licensing fees,
and varying terms and conditions.
This made the system extremely unorganized
and difficult to manage.
So, in 1970, Dee Hock, the chairman of the
BankAmericard committee, proposed the idea
of spinning off BankAmericard into its own
company.
Bank of America would agree and a new company
called NBI or National BankAmericard Inc was
created for domestic relations and Dee Hock
would be made CEO.
However, Bank of America retained the right
to continue issuing BankAmericards outside
of the US and forming new partnerships.
It didn’t take long for this to turn into
a massive mess as well though.
By 1972, international partners were starting
to get frustrated with Bank of America and
wanted a more streamlined process.
So, Bank of America would seek help from Dee
Hock.
Eventually, they would work out a deal and
create a new company called IBANCO or International
Bankcard Company for international relations.
This new system of IBANCO and NBI was actually
pretty effective, but by 1976, the companies
came to the conclusion that there was no reason
to operate as separate entities.
So, in 1976, the two companies merged and
created what we now know as Visa.
MODERN DAY VISA:
Now that all of the background issues were
taken care of, Visa could focus on improving
the service.
This included supporting more currencies,
offering cash withdrawals around the clock,
launching the debit card, and so on and so
forth.
But by far their biggest challenge was addressing
credit card fraud.
Unfortunately, this couldn’t really be addressed
until technology advanced much more, but Visa
introduced fraud protections services as soon
as they could.
In 1993, for instance, Visa started utilizing
neural network technology to better identify
fraudulent payments.
But their biggest step against fraud didn’t
come till 2004 when they introduced advanced
authorization.
Advanced authorization leverages machine learning
and risk management tools to assign a risk
score to every Visa transaction in real time.
For example, if you go grocery shopping every
friday, and one week you go on a wednesday,
that payment would be assigned a higher risk
score.
Similarly, if you live in Austin, but go on
vacation to New York and make a purchase there,
that transaction would have a much higher
risk score.
While this system is quite effective and has
allowed for more consumer friendly fraud policies,
critics have argued that the system is intrusive.
In order to identify these anomalies, Visa
needed to know your purchasing habits and
travel life pretty well.
Despite these concerns though, Visa’s growth
has never slowed down as consumer spending
just keeps going up year after year.
In 1997, Visa reached $1 trillion in annual
payment volume.
Within just 10 years though, this over quadrupled
to $4.4 trillion.
Anyway, in 2008, Visa would go public that
same year, and since then, the stock has run
over 1100% making them the 13th largest company
in the world with a valuation of $438 billion.
And when you control the credit card market
and have 51% net margins, that’s really
not that surprising.
Do you guys have a Visa powered credit card?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’re a master at
milking those credit card rewards.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.